est-ce que ce soir vous autour de la
table vous avez une déclaration d'amour
à faire on attend toujours
il a tendance à tout ça peut peut-être
non mais c'est vrai si j'arrive
déclaration d'amour à faire ce soir je
serai demain c'est la saint valentin
dans un instant on saura si fatou va
nous appeler et dans un instant mathieu
j'aurai quelque chose pour aaa
un petit regret un petit truc c'est trop
tard c'est moi nous dire quelque chose
oui je crois que en 45 ans et mon âge je
suis pas de nom mais donc les jeux j'ai
dû connaître une saint valentin
je me suis toujours retrouvé seul comme
un con à la saint-valentin encore le cas
demain soir à écouter malheureusement je
ne peux rien faire pour nom soit j'ai
bien compris vous avez une déclaration
d'amour à faire si vous voulez affaire
fait là maintenant ou taisez vous à tout
jamais fait une déclaration d'amour une
déclaration d'amitié castaldi moi j'ai
déjà fait ce soir non tu n'as pas
vraiment fait
bah oui mais enfin après jérôme flore et
vous pas juré aux fleurs donc pas si moi
je suis pas déjà fragile moi non mais
moi j'ai je suis je suis non très très
beaux draps pas mal de ces noms qu'on
ait fait la même personne n'avait fait
une belle déclaration oui oui mais s'est
très aisément on pouvait sortir ça mais
non mais je suis perdu mon amour de ma
femme c'est un bonheur de pouvoir rien
quand on travaille le matin d'avoir le
sourire et se dire la vie c'est beau
voilà donc merci
mais là et nous bah moi on en parle
beaucoup beaucoup de lui ici
donc voilà je suis très très pudique
mais tout ce que je ne dis pas il le
sait voilà donc je t'aime mon cousin
opus c'est pas touche
oui bien sûr touche à touche apatow pas
touche patoche la touffe t'embrasse j'ai
même eu de l'émotion
j'aime être aussi les poing dans la
gueule c'est jean-michel fait je suis
célibataire donc à moi que je trouve dix
ans après faire une déclaration d'amitié
d'amour mais j'ai pas voilà non j'aurais
plutôt envie de faire déclare son amour
d'amitié j'ai déjà fait à mathieu avoue
ainsi vous savez je suis depuis dix ans
je quitterai jamais voilà à tous les
chroniqueurs jeu c'est une vraie famille
et franchement je n'y arrive plus
important que la famille mes enfants ma
maman évidemment voilà mais à la future
l'attend allez-y faites vous plaisir et
puis on terminera par gilles et on verra
ce qu il fatto appel avec votre deuxième
déclaration pour l'instant par aman on a
coupé le téléphone de factures qu'elle y
voit personne quelqu'un à part jean
michaud croit qu'elle aime personne va
enfin c'est ce que j'allais le dire
c'est comment choisit pas sa famille
mais moi j'ai choisi de la choisir
décidé de la choisir est je voulais dire
j'ai envie que pour moi tu faisais comme
partie de ma famille je suis même plus
proche de 3 que certains membres de ma
famille et je veux dire que tu étais
toujours là pour moi je serai toujours
pour toi et je suis estime énormément
j'étais mal
[Applaudissements]
c'est les bonnes notes
[Musique]
avec les rebonds mais c'est à résidence
est ce que vous voulez que ça demain
c'est pic d'audience aussi typé mousse
[Rires]
mais moi je ça fait 14 ans je partage
avec anne carette tout le monde connaît
c'est cyril d'ailleurs qui fait qu'un
jour j'ai rencontré anne tout simplement
parce que jacques lang avait inversé un
rendez vous avec un autre ça merci jack
lang
non c'était 4 ça fait 14 ans qu'on
partage dovi on vit toujours dans deux
appartements dossier puisque vous vivez
dans un dans une niche dans ses 16 ans
[Rires]
mais pas bien frais ouais je continue et
donc on en a rien c'est parfois curieux
l'amour parce que on n'a rien on n'a
rien en commun
bien sûr c'est à dire elle aime tout ce
que je déteste et je déteste tout ce
qu'elle aime pas ça quoi cette saison
beaucoup de couples d'ailleurs bien une
chanson de patrick bruel fait tout ce
que je déteste
celle ci demande ce qu'il dise des
mensonges d'or
ouais ouais donc à l'on regarde 4,9
contre ali qui arrive dans l'équipe dans
une manif à nous parle en fait ma
déclaration d'amour watts avec la
réaffirmation fin du mois n'a rien fait
moi je voudrais passer un message
d'amour à tous les personnes qui en ont
besoin
bien sûr assez joli ses jambes toi ça
nous ceux qui auront pas de valentin ou
valentine demain sur clermont c'était
important que il faut en donner
et aussi à mon chéri qui m'a donné la
plus belle chose que j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est mon fils de 17 membres avant août
à l'udc a pu noter aussi série bien vous
aussi parce que vous m'avez permis
d'être ici paris tu cherches et voilà je
joue en fa dièse pour fêter ça en même
temps les
moi c'est un peu débile mais je crois
que j'ai toujours voulu dire toute ma
famille mes parents mon papa maman et
toutes mes soeurs on est super proche et
que ça que je les aime et en fait ça
fait bizarre de verbaliser face à un peu
débile c'est un peu niais mais voilà
j'en profite ce soir et je vous hais
ah là là là on s'attend à tout la has
est le pic d'audience à ces parties là
il est à toi et or c'est ce que s'est
dit vas-y massatois clash son père
lachaise
c'est moche oui les manques émotion sur
ma fille blessée parce que c'est super
sympa le chimiste au dos et justement
dire que moi j'aimais profondément la
famille qu'effectivement la seconde
famille qui se trouvent ici que j'aime
profondément la mienne de vraies
familles qui traversent une petite zone
de turbulences et que j'aime mais
finalement mon homme
on va contre la cie peuvent lui passer
le temps je vous dis voilà alors pour le
maire de d'étudiants et que l'on fait
toujours l'amour et l'humour ensemble
que je laime puisqu'il ya moins que
demain et merci chéri de m'avoir acheter
des oeufs nous avons mis dans le frigo
comme tu le mets dans le sms avant alors
qu'on est gilles est ce que tu as toi le
bel éphèbe déclaration d'amour à faire
alors moi j'ai pas du tout prévu mais si
je devais en faire je la ferai ma soeur
le hamas route à ces normes
[Rires]
sinequa non mais souvent vous dites
qu'on gâche les moments d'émotion mais
là vous à strasbourg
ça me tue à choper de séquencer pas si
toi ça j'étais bien mort sa soeur julie
j'adore alors donc 3 4 reprend pour le
coup là dessus représentent donc je dis
à ceux effectivement très sincère parce
que c'est ma grande soeur c'est celle
dont je suis le plus proche qu'on a plus
de mer qu'on a plus de grand mère et que
du coup on est tous les deux comme ça
c'est celle qui sait tout de moi je sais
tout d'elle et c'est la personne dont je
suis le plus proche au monde et est donc
elle m'invite à noël pour fêter noël
avec elle parce que c'est moi je suis
seul où elle m'invite par exemple samedi
soir je vais regarder la télévision chez
elle samedi soir ce samedi-là et
j'embrasse très fort si elle regarde
attention tu passes un seul mineur et
comme j'ai jamais dis parce qu'on se
retourne et eps de boulot voilà je laime
très très très très fort
[Musique]
ttc pourtant elle va détester lé petit
dit qu'elle déteste ça tant pis ça il
faut le dire mais oui ok c'est la reine
ont déjà mais m qu'est ce que tu crois
que ce qu'on lille va pouvoir casser un
peu l'armure là mais bien un truc un peu
touche avec ça serait bien que vous
[Applaudissements]
chers amis éméchés pas le cou à la con
aux téléspectateurs vous me donner tort
depuis des années gnagnagna toutes ces
conneries ça donne vraiment à quelqu'un
ça peut être beau à voir quelqu'un
d'autre mais ça peut être moi en train
de jouer la wii mais bon je le donne
nous un mail à fond quand je donne avec
la musique
d'abord j'ai le statut et à toi avec un
grand t comme tajine j'ai reçu deux
coups au coeur quand le téléphone a
sonné j'ai cru que c'était toi deux fois
la troisième fois je suis sûr qu'il va
redonner ce sera toi ils s'entendraient
à voix et chérie je t'aime quoi qu'il
arrive c'est la fin la plus merveilleuse
du monde et ce thème